turning to the coronavirus where
infections are shattering records here
in the u.s health officials reported
more than a million new cases yesterday
now that number does include saturday
and sunday totals and of course
hospitalizations have not risen as
quickly however the seven-day average of
new cases
is now close to half a million a day and
that's concerning meanwhile the fda has
authorized pfizer's booster for 12 to 15
year olds and for kids age 5 to 11 who
have compromised immune systems it also
decided boosters can be given five
months after a complete vaccination
instead of six the changes still need
cdc approval omar vi franca is at a
testing center in frisco texas for us
that's near dallas omar good
morning good morning the positivity rate
here in texas is more than 33 that means
more than one in three pcr tests are
coming back positive take a look at this
testing site behind me they're expecting
to test hundreds of people today in fact
there were dozens that were lined up
before this place even open
we get it people are tired of hearing
about numbers they're tired of hearing
about positivity rates and
hospitalization rates but doctors say
what people need to pay attention to is
how this is affecting children
at cook children's medical center in
fort worth texas hospital beds are
filling up fast with patients are your
patients
younger kids or your teenage kids that
you're seeing unfortunately we're still
seeing both so really anywhere in the
spectrum we've had some babies that were
a few weeks old dr mary suzanne
whitworth is the medical director of
infectious diseases at cook children's
where more than two dozen children are
hospitalized with covid right now
one of those patients is eight-month-old
olivia mckinney she was born more than
three months early at just one pound one
ounce her mother marandi patterson says
she had been doing great
until last month she was hospitalized a
month ago with a different type of virus
and then she recovered from that just
fine and then we were doing great and
then she caught covet and
here we are olivia has been on oxygen
for several days now and is unable to
eat normally i was devastated i i just
sat there i cried because i didn't know
like
what her fate would be like it's
affecting kids everywhere across the
nation an average of 378 children were
admitted to the hospital every day from
december 22nd to december 28th that's a
66 percent increase from the week before
and the highest rate of pediatric
hospitalization so far during the
pandemic what would you tell people
based on the predicament you're in
about this disease it's scary and you
never really think that it would be your
child but my daughter can sit here and
she's coughing
30 45 minutes at a time
and she can't catch her breath and
they're having to try to suction and
everything like that to try to get her
to just be able to breathe again
school districts around the country are
paying attention schools in detroit
newark cleveland and milwaukee are going
to remote learning which could last
several weeks gail
got a lot of worried parents out there
thank you very much omar